le tournage est déterminé il est il
était terminé en tout cas vous souvenez
on en a parlé de nombreuses fois sur ce
plateau ici à tel point qu'un jour ils
sont arrivés au château de Windsor sans
vraiment prévenir vous souvenez vous
avez une caméra secrétaire c'est ça
redouard juni à l'époque avait dit
écoutez non vous vous pouvez voir la
reine il n'y a pas de de d'objection à
cela en revanche vous ne pénétrerez pas
à l'intérieur du château Twitter avec
les caméras de Netflix ils ont tenté à
de nombreuses reprises alors voyant
qu'il n'obtenaient pas grand chose du
palais bah ils ont réorienté ce
documentaire ce documentaire qu'à la
base devait être très Royal très scoop
et tout ça c'est devenu un peu un
documentaire qui va être découpé on dit
qu'il y aurait une dizaine d'épisodes
qui suit Harry et Megane quasiment un
peu au quotidien et l'homme à la plage
c'est surtout pas Larry Mégane qui fait
du sport on sait qu'il a repris le pneu
par exemple uniquement
le polo voilà il joue au polo désormais
et entre autres
il est vrai pour revenir vraiment à
l'actu ce documentaire apparemment c'est
apprendre avec des pincettes mais
apparemment d'après ce tableau qui est
quand même très bien informé il serait
reporté il était attendu pour le 9
novembre alors la date n'était pas prise
au hasard puisque c'est de la sortie de
la 5e saison de the crown donc Netflix
comptait vraiment surfer sur cette vague
là il semblerait que il soit reporté en
parallèle de la fin de l'année mais on
est encore sûr de rien alors de quoi
d'ailleurs qui fait déjà
frémiring Palace pour ceux qui
connaissent pas cette série que j'ai vu
qui est incroyable c'est toute
l'histoire de
c'est la partie la plus croustillante
puisque là on va découvrir Diana avec
Dodi le tunnel PAF voilà entre autres on
revient sur les années 90 et en effet
c'est la femme il y en a 17 et les
conséquences
92 il y a 1000 choses vous verrez
Benjamin mais ils sont très inquiets de
cette quand même bah disons que je sers
lui paraît déjà auprès de son entourage
ce serait ouvert de certaines
inquiétudes parce que l'image qu'il a
dans the crown pour ceux qui ont suivi
la série ici c'est pas très gentil
c'est dans certaines éclairage à
certaines langues qui est appuyé ils
prennent plutôt un peu la défense entre
guillemets l'angle de Diana qui est très
bonne hein
est-ce que la famille royale est plus
inquiète de la saison 5 de the crown ou
du documentaire
à mon avis ils ont fait les deux c'est
un prix gros à mon avis il fait
l'ensemble Jérôme Caron juste pour qu'on
soit bien précis ils en sont où Harry
Megane avec la famille est-ce que c'est
c'est
déjà c'était pas c'était pas ouf c'était
pas dingue et la semaine d'obsèques
c'est pas super bien passé en fait pour
tout un tas de ce qu'on a vu nous alors
oui l'idée c'était officiellement tout
se passe bien après il y a eu plusieurs
problèmes le premier problème d'abord
c'est qu'il est arrivé en retard il a
son quand Isabelle 2 quand on apprend la
mort d'Elizabeth II Charles avant de
rendre la nouvelle officielle le roi a
décide de prévenir tous ses enfants et
ses petits-enfants on dirait avant
qu'ils le découvre sur regardant les
bandeaux d'infos le problème c'est qu'il
n'arrive pas à il dit téléphone à Harry
conversation de 20 à 30 minutes très
très longue pendant lequel Harry dit
est-ce que je peux venir avec Mégane
Charles dit non tu viens pas avec Mégane
c'est hors de question donc haribood
arrive frustré arrière argumente
de la famille royale eux prennent
l'avion et ils vont en Écosse aux
chevets de la reine lui hydrate cet
avion là puisqu'il il a une bonne heure
de retard donc il doit trouver un jet
privé à lui 30 000 euros merde c'est pas
gagné et mais bon et il arrive
5 minutes après 5 minutes avant pardon
qu'on annonce officiellement la mort de
la reine Elizabeth de Charles essaye de
le joindre dans l'avion mais il n'y
arrive pas et en fait il apprend la mort
officielle de sa grand-mère dans l'avion
d'un fou sur son portable dans son avion
c'est quand même quelqu'un qui voit pas
parce que dans l'avion c'est pas facile
quand même de alors juste comment il a
comment il remporter cette bagarre il a
comme il a réussi à imposer Mégane qui a
quand même salement bavé sur la famille
on va voir les extraits entre les
problèmes de racisme les preuves de
dépression franchement elle peut pas les
blairer bon comment est-ce qu'il a
réussi à la faire accéder au basket
était quand même dans le cortège moi je
l'ai vu à côté de son mari qui n'avait
pas le costume d'ailleurs de militaire
n'est pas le droit de porter des armes
de la marine anglaise on va retirer son
prédicat d'Altesse royale en effet il
était là en 6e avec son prédicat oui
avec les médailles militaires que vous
voyez derrière lui et les différentes
distinctions donc de même que un trou
d'ailleurs l'autre fils lui ah bon on va
regarder on a des images de ça justement
j'ai dit que j'avais vraiment besoin
d'aide parce qu'ils ont dit c'est nous
sommes de tout cœur avec vous car nous
voyons bien à quel point c'est difficile
mais nous pouvons rien faire pour vous
protéger car vous n'êtes pas une
employée de cette institution vous aviez
des pensées suicidaires oui c'était un
très très clair on peut pas simplement
partir comme ça il faut bien comprendre
que quand j'ai intégré la famille
ça a été la dernière fois jusqu'à notre
arrivée ici que j'ai vu mon passeport
mon permis de conduire mes clés le
prince héritier en compagnie de sa mère
Kate que l'on vient de voir la reine
consort qui mène cette
délégation royale et détail très
touchant je crois que c'est la première
fois que la princesse Charlotte porte un
chapeau alors c'était les images de la
fin on a vu Mégane parce que ce qu'on a
vu avant c'est l'interview qui avait
fait grand scandale qui n'est pas sans
rappel d'ailleurs celle que Diana avait
fait à son époque assez
et la couronne et son ex-mari donc
aujourd'hui les relations sont-elles
apaisées entre Mégane et la famille où
est-ce que c'est tendu et bien là je
vais dire qu'il faut vraiment pour le
coup être dans l'intimité du clan pour
pouvoir vraiment dire si les relations
sont apaisées ou pas maintenant il y a
très peu de chances que les relations
soient apaisées puisqu'il y a des
premiers signes quand même qui nous sont
donnés et qui montrent quand même que
Harry et Megane vont continuer à faire
machin libre comme ils l'ont bah voilà
voulu des départs on rappelle quand même
que s'il quitte la famille royale c'est
sur leur propre désir c'est eux qui
demandent pour ne plus faire partie de
l'institution il y a eu cette fameuse
photo qui a été diffusée samedi sur
Twitter le compte Twitter de la flûte
le roi Charles III et l'épouse camélia
choisissent de poser pour un cliché
officiel nous dit-on aux côtés de
William et de Kate Middleton alors c'est
pas tellement le fait que Kate et
William sont associés à la photo moi qui
me perturbe un peu à la limite pourquoi
pas ce qui me perturbe c'est qu'on n'a
pas choisi uniquement de mettre en avant
le roi et la nouvelle reine qu'on sort
le fait que d'emblée on associe le
nouveau prince et la nouvelle princesse
de Galles bah en effet laissera quand
même supposer on est
plus glamour de ce côté-là que du côté
des anciens quand même ce sera le
globalement
protocolaire moins élargi qu'il désire
restreindre maintenant on sait aussi que
ils étaient présents à ri et Mégane au
moment où a eu lieu cette photo à cette
photo elle est prise le 18 septembre
c'est le fameux jour vous savez de ce
qu'on a appelé la réception du siècle où
il recevait les sacs son chef d'État
presque présent déjà avant la veille des
obsèques donc il aurait pu aussi je
trouve faire une autre photo plus
familiale avec l'ensemble peut-être des
deux enfants le fait qu'il ne le fait
que le palais n'a pas souhaité pardon
communiquer là la démontrerait que ils
ont peut-être tenté d'obtenir des choses
du côté d'Ariel Mégane et qu'ils ne les
ont peut-être pas donc il y a pas de
chance qui reviennent dans la famille
puis qui sont partis il y a peu de
chance personnelle
sur leur dernier personne oui l'argent
les deux premières années c'est papa qui
a manqué
d'ailleurs papa comment il a pris avec
la dame qui est parti là
monsieur
je vous assure il faut vraiment à
nouveau être sauf si Jérôme à des
montants précis mais
le truc avec la fortune des Windsor
c'est que c'est extrêmement compliqué
parce que c'est comme si vous possédez
le Louvre et que il fallait déterminer
non mais c'est à peu près
la plus grande collection de dessin du
monde elle a la plus grande collection
de timbres du monde enfin elle l'avait
parce que maintenant il va changer de
timbre le temps qu'il va y avoir il va y
avoir Charles qui va changer
on va quand même écouler ceux qui
suivent l'état de la livre on va quand
même pas non plus voilà donc on va
écouler tout ça et oui c'est très très
compliqué lui le Charles a hérité du
danger du duché de Lancastre
qui est dont les derniers Lancastre
c'est un grand duché c'est un grand une
succession de domaine avec plein plein
des chants des châteaux comme l'amour
est dans le pré qui fait beaucoup de
ça
un domaine bio et ça fait marrer tout le
monde donc pas de chance qu'il revienne
à jamais Royal les deux faut qu'ils
subvienne à leurs besoins d'où le
Netflix d'où les 100 bars excuse-moi
parce que ça rappelle quand même on l'a
dit aussi Netflix ils ont touché 99
millions d'euros presque ça a été dit en
trois paiements ils en sont à 66 là il
en manque encore 33 voilà s'ils arrivent
vraiment à terminer les auront et alors
il y a cette amuse autobiographie dont
on n'a pas encore parlé
du camping
édition du Pingouin oui bah pour rire il
a touché 20 millions en a falloir de 20
millions de dollars ils sont quand même
blindés c'est hallucinant
ah non mais moi j'aurais déposé une
princesse pardon oh mais mais voilà
je plaisante ça va c'est une blague oh
alors il y en a deux qui font où
peut-être qu'elle elle aurait aimé se
marier avec un homme fortuné c'est vrai
aussi
alors au départ au départ cette histoire
elle est bien commencé c'est vrai qu'ils
nous ont fait rêver mais il arrive moi
j'étais plus j'étais plus fan de Kate ok
mais voilà
tout est bien commencé
c'est pas deux points voici les images
de ce mariage qui à l'époque faisait
rêver tout le monde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors ça ça fait long feu parce que très
vite il y a eu du rifi dans la famille
pourquoi ça s'est dégradé alors on a vu
la vidéo tout à l'heure en avance mais
bon on l'a expliqué qu'elle était bon la
qualité malheureuse qui était dépressive
c'était quand même
marrés qui sont dépressifs ça s'est
dégradé parce qu'en fait le truc c'est
que elle elle pensait garder une part de
liberté dans sa vie quotidienne de
pouvoir mener les projets qui lui tenait
à cœur la cause des femmes la cause des
enfants les diverses diverses chantiers
en Afrique et puis il se trouve que dans
la famille royale en fait c'est une
vraie entreprise avec des des secteurs
déterminés par personne par habitude par
tradition et donc elle a pas pu
exactement se mouvoir
ah non tu n'as pas le droit de t'emparer
de la cause des femmes
on peut le faire mais par exemple la
reine qu'on sort Camilla
pour les femmes battus
dans la boue et elle revient du diable
Aubert ah ça c'est l'exploitation elle
était détestée elle a piqué le Charles a
déjà de l'époque de Diana et la voie la
qui revient en Rennes
mieux apparemment
il est bien mais elle a l'air méchante
non non non
mais elle est belle
pas du tout
qu'elles aimaient dans le fond de
l'épouserait jamais parce qu'il était
marié
la trajectoire de la dame elle était
Dame de Pique elle devient dame de cœur
et elle continue encore à morfler vous
savez ce que vous souvenez
75 ans elle a eu 75 ans il y a pas très
longtemps vogue lui fait squatter la
couverture de son magazine elle accepte
de jouer de jeu elle se change elle se
rechange elle perd du poids on la
maquille on la démaquille elle chante ça
parce que la lumière n'est pas bonne et
bien au final elle ne chope pas la
couverture
particulier
les événements
on va rester
on va rester sur Arrêt méga parce que
effectivement ça c'est en toile de fond
c'est à mon avis eux qui vont un petit
peu pourrir l'histoire de leur père ça
va être très compliqué alors comme il
cherche du taf on se met de la séquence
où ils ont carrément été chez Disney et
là franchement ils ont demandé du boulot
mais comme on l'aurait fait nous t'as
pas tu as pas un boulot pour ma meuf
s'il te plaît ça va coûter un peu d'oser
regardez
Mégane et Harry débarquent sur le marché
de l'emploi ça donne une vidéo à
lucinante ou Harry place sa femme chez
Disney vous savez qu'elle fait des
doublages oh vraiment vous le saviez non
je ne savais pas vous avez la surprise
mais oui elle est vraiment intéressée il
est impossible aujourd'hui pour Meghan
Markle d'avoir un rôle dans une comédie
romantique on va la voir apparaître nu
ou même en brassant un autre homme que
le prince Harry non tout ça reste
strictement impensable c'est quand même
c'est quand même cavalier quand même
excusez-moi mais vous savez ça marche en
train de vie qui est complètement dément
on ne peut même pas s'imaginer ils sont
à montechito peut-être à part ça
peut-être même
très joli
et voilà ils ont besoin d'argent pour
vous donner un tout petit exemple parmi
l'autre ils ont engagé comme chef de la
sécurité quand même Christopher sunshez
l'ancien numéro 1 de la sécurité sociale
Obama et Alberto Alvarez qui est
l'ancien chef de la sécurité de Michael
Jackson est-ce que vous imaginez pas ces
gens-là pour pour 1000 euros par jour
alors une question sur quoi une question
parce que les tableaux sont pleins
des propos de personnel de Meghan Markle
qui qui me disent à quel point ils ont
été malheureux à quel point ils étaient
tyranniques et odieuses avec c'est vrai
bah il y a une enquête
il y a un bouquin qui est sorti
là-dessus carrément en tout cas a priori
visiblement les mouches les mouches ont
changé d'âne et ils étaient sur sur la
sur la ville euh
je plaisante comment ça va et maintenant
c'est votre aide maintenant
félicitations mais alors le vrai
problème c'est que apparemment
apparemment le prince Charles maintenant
le roi Charles le roi Charles III
apparemment il a il a déjà fait plein de
boulettes
alors moi je l'ai vu on va voir les
images mais quand même on l'a vu agacée
mais non il est il est très capricieux
quand même sanguin
il fait comme ça regardez les images
c'est un petit truc c'est un petit
regard
[Musique]
vous avez vu il se rend compte qu'il
s'est trompé de dates je pense qu'on est
le 12 en réalité on est le 13 il n'y a
pas plus superstitieux car Windsor et
surtout avec le chiffre 13 il faut quand
même savoir qu'en 70 ans de règne
Élisabeth de n'a jamais présidé une
table où ils étaient assis à 13 la
cabine le Britannia ne n’a jamais
comporté de cabines numéro 13 et ben on
peut peut-être se dire aussi que je dis
et merde en plus on est le 13 et voilà
cette tâche qui a proposé supers
une semaine tous les jours 8 heures par
jour devant les caméras entre un
enterrer sa mère en costume il change
trois fois par jour de costard il
enchaîne tout sans problème on a gardé
un truc sur 10 jours stop c'est ça on a
gardé le mépris vis-à-vis des gens
chez moi
est-ce que on a vu la reine d'Angleterre
feu et Elisabeth on n'a jamais vu la
bête faire petite comme ça de porter des
gants donc déjà ça aurait été un petit
peu moins dangereux
c'est une femme différente il faut
accepter
on a 50 ans on a une autre on a encore
des images
sont accablées sont accaba regardez
il est un petit peu il y a un petit peu
de dénu quand même voilà il faut qu'il
descend le roi bah faut bien regarder
regardez
je vous l'accorde et au revoir en effet
que c'est
lui peut-être l'ombre d'une chose quand
même en tout petit peu et simplement je
voudrais dire que il n'a pas été élevé
comme monsieur et madame tout le monde
depuis qu'il est tout petit on lui dit
un jour tu seras roi Charles un jour tu
seras roi il appartient à la galaxie
Windsor et de ce ne sont pas des êtres
comme vous êtes élégant quand même
le jour de l'enterrement de sa mère
quand même il a viré tout le personnel
d'un de ses palais
avec ses équipes et vous redéployer les
équipes qui sont sur place mais juste le
jour de l'enterrement de sa mère non
vous préférez qu'on fasse qu'on fasse
semblant pendant trois semaines et puis
qu'on les a pas de respect oui de toute
façon évidemment
c'est quand même la blague à part c'est
la situation est terrible pour le peuple
le peuple britannique comment il va
faire le roi avec tout ça parce que
entre la dîme ça coûte paraît-il une
livre 50 par anglais 66 par contribuable
très exactement
en train de vie qu'il ne va plus être le
même maintenant la crosse le danger de
Charles III c'est de ne pas trop
estomper la magie parce que si ça
fonctionne les Windsor c'est parce que
les chevaux ils sont blancs les 46 sont
en or ils vivent à Buckingham Palace
c'est pour cela que ça que ça fonctionne
un petit carrosse en plaqué or ça passe
le problème c'est la première ministre
la première ministre elle a déjà
interdit d'une sortie
juste le problème c'est que visiblement
dans la série Netflix pour revenir à
Angers visiblement Mégane et le petit
prince avait annoncé que son père était
justement un peu comme ça un peu
capricieux un peu mal élevé un peu
grossier même c'est ça le problème oui
mais justement
ils font un remontage de la série qui
soit plus favorable à la famille donc et
il y a aussi apparemment une vraie
compétition ils sortent les photos
officielles en même temps le couple
Harry et Megane en même temps que ceux
de la famille royale et en fait ils
suivent le même planning mais chacun
dans leur coin et il y a une espèce de
compétition comme ça qui serait le vrai
problème avec Henri Mégane c'est que ils
veulent exister en tant qu'arrivier
Mégane mais ils sont dus et du chef de
sucer c'est ce qui les fait existait
et donc vraiment c'est donc c'est très
compliqué pour eux parce que un jour ils
sont du Chai du cancer les arrange
quelque part c'est ce que certains gens
pensent ils sont du quai du chaise c'est
parce que ça allait dérange ah non non
on n'est pas comme ça vous comprenez on
est libre on fait ce qu'on en même temps
on signe attendez qu'ils aient plus
d'oseille ils vont revenir au château de
ferme mais c'est probablement ce qui
s'est dit il est pardon c'est
probablement ce qui s'est dit là on
pense quand même qu'il y a eu une
discussion franche entre le roi et son
fils ou à un moment donné il a dit voilà
je suis prêt à sortir le chéquier même
si j'ai du pain avec des stylos alors
justement alors que tout cela s'arrête
pour tenter de les musulmer mais ceux
qui sembleraient c'est que ce soit trop
tard parce que le contrat d'édition
voilà et voilà
ils vont faire un chèque comme pour
Andrew la reine elle avait elle avait
payé pour qu'on étouffe l'affaire là il
va faire un jeu pour qu'on ait tous le
livre croyez-moi je déconner les rois
c'est mes copains euh on a on a eu prévu
pour début de novembre
on a un autre extrait où on voit voilà
là pour le coup le roi Charles
il est plutôt sympathique il y a aussi
un livre et finalisation est-ce qu'il a
fait donc peut-être ça l'humanise un
petit peu voilà un petit peu c'est trop
bon
[Musique]
voilà donc il a un petit peu d'humour
mais qui collectionnent les lunettes de
toilette crâne non mais justement et ça
ne me manque pas
vous avez un livre qui sort sur la reine
comment s'appelle celui i love Elizabeth
I love
il les avait deux oh là là donc pour
résumer
Mégane et Harry vont revenir au bercail
parce qu'il y a plus de pognon
ils vont préparer William apprendre la
place de Charles parce qu'il va pas
rester longtemps Charles
et comme c'est les plus glamour
William et sa femme sa valait très vite
c'était tout compris ils vont enlever
une petite chose peut-être d'abord il y
a d'abord la fameuse opération que l'on
appelle déjà golden horbeg voilà alors
qui sera l'opération le nom militaire le
code qui a été donné pour le
couronnement du roi Charles III qu'on a
le temps l'année prochaine au mois de
juin et alors il y aura la première
visite à l'étranger du roi Charles qui
est prévu en France en France très bien
et ben écoutez on va à peu près